Kerry Lake now participating in a prayer
circle to try to pray away the stolen
election you know there used to be a
time where these religious conservatives
would try to get people to pray away the
gay they would say if you pray enough
and if I pray enough maybe you won't be
gay no more if you remember that Viral
clip they have moved on I guess from
trying to pray for people not to be gay
or for themselves not to be gay I don't
even know
um
to praying for the winner of an election
to lose that's fundamentally what they
are praying for here and you will see
Carrie Lake in this video if you were if
you were watching with her head bowed in
prayer
um
guys this this country is really messed
up tweet
tweaking heads for now is the season and
the hour for things to begin to shift
and change as Global Freedom shall cover
this Earth yeah so I would not bet on
that one working necessarily I don't
know that it would put too many eggs in
that basket for lack of a better term
and Kerry Lake continues to invoke God
here's another segment and this is very
much like you know when when an athlete
says well I we I I have to thank God for
this victory
and it's sort of like
God is now choosing like who wins a
tennis match that's what's going on or
the like a curling thing or a soccer
game it's it's God and why is god making
the choices in this way did the other
team not pray enough did they not pray
correctly it's all very weird but Carrie
Lake applying that here to uh her
election I guess people can for starters
pray we we really need God yeah in in
this world we need God in our hearts and
our homes and in our country he quite
literally doesn't have a prayer of being
the next governor of Arizona and I know
God's making a big comeback in this
country I feel it I talk to people who
say I started to return to church I
brought God back into our family's lives
it's so important right now we're due
for a couple of Miracles I think it's
just such a fantasy world that these
people live in but I also believe we
have on top of of that we have a really
good court case and we're going to open
people's eyes to what went wrong you
know there's times I felt just like the
voters out there in Arizona
um despondent over the last couple of
weeks right because we had such a we
have such an amazing movement and then I
think about what God you know our father
is doing he's imagine if you if your dad
said to you I have such great hope for
you and I I believe in you so much that
I'm going to put you in charge of
something difficult oh this is just so
crazy listen if God wanted her to win
why didn't she just win right like is is
God is all-knowing and all-powerful and
involved in every absolutely every
decision Sports decisions and you know
who wins the lottery and who wins
elections God is involved everywhere and
yet God allowed Katie Hobbs to seemingly
get more votes and to have the election
certified and imminently to be
inaugurated as the governor of Arizona
and then now you have to pray for God to
change his mind did you not pray enough
before or did you pray the wrong way or
did Katie Hobbs have better prayer or
more prayer it it's just insane and it's
the same type of grift that would get
people to even donate to somebody like
Carrie Lake in the first place will have
all these carry late Clips if you can
stomach them on our Instagram which you
can find at davidpackman show and of
course they will all be on the YouTube
channel
at youtube.com slash the David Pacman
show make sure you're subscribed it is
free and we will be back right after
this